one
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
me cansé si me cansé me cansé de que las
personas sigan pensando en la ciencia
como esa actividad lejana como esa
actividad que únicamente realizan unos
pocos unos pocos que se cree que tienen
esta apariencia que están todo el día
con los pelos alborotados y usando
siempre una bata de laboratorio
esto no es así la ciencia es una
actividad hermosa realizada por personas
de carne y hueso
personas que si bien pueden tener esta
apariencia
además
pueden tener
esta otra apariencia
soy look hasta sol y no estudió biología
y les vengo a contar una historia un
relato que si bien no va a ser un cuento
de hadas para tratar de dejarles es
hermosos sentimientos que uno tiene
cuando leemos la frase colorín colorado
este cuento se ha acabado
hoy les vengo a contar una historia
una especie de trayecto que yo he
empezado a caminar y que me ha llevado a
la pauta de que la ciencia es un modo de
vida
si bien podríamos estar discutiendo días
enteros para tratar de dar una respuesta
a una pregunta que parece sencilla pero
que no lo es que es la ciencia o que son
las ciencias
como dije dar una respuesta a estas
preguntas sería bastante complicado pero
desde mi punto de vista de estudiante y
de aficionado por la ciencia me gusta
pensar de la misma como un modo de vida
hoy les voy a contar lo lindo que puede
ser transitar la vida cuando uno lo hace
de la mano de la niñez
cuando uno se reafirma como un niño o
como le dicen en otras partes del mundo
como un arte la palabra nerd la hemos
escuchado un montón de veces en nuestra
escuela en nuestro barrio y hasta
nuestro grupo de amigos es una palabra
que forma parte de nuestro día a día
pero entonces si es tan cotidiana porque
cuando nos dicen la frase vos sos unión
yo o vos sos un nardo siempre lo
relacionamos con algo negativo o hasta
con un insulto o peor porque cuando nos
dicen esta frase siempre pensamos que no
está bueno saber nada que es algo en lo
cual no nos tenemos que convertir esa
idea a mí me parece muy triste por dos
motivos en primer lugar porque ellos
siempre me consideré un narco y en
segundo lugar porque nunca lo pude
disimular me acuerdo que cuando tan sólo
tenía 5 años en plena época de
jardincito participé de un curso
un curso de dinosaurios
quien nunca quiso ser un paleontólogo
quien nunca quiso estar en un parque
jurásico descubriendo el mundo
este curso estaba destinado a gente más
grande gente de primaria y hasta de
secundaria pero yo con 5 años y sin
saber ni leer ni escribir quería
participar es tan así que yo le insistí
mucho a mis viejos para que fueran a
hablar con la profe ellos accedieron y
fueron a hablar con ella le dijeron
profe cristina lucas no lee ni escribe
pero si usted le pone una imagen de un
dinosaurio y si realmente le transmite
con entusiasmo lo que usted quiere decir
el levante andar que no le queden dudas
y así fue
termine participando del curso y fui a
todas ya cada una de las clases y para
mí eso fue una experiencia hermosa
no solo porque bueno termine conociendo
un montón de gente sino que además la
profe cristina está profe que me había
aceptado y que me había recibido en el
curso cuando terminó me escribió una
carta en un pequeño cuadernito de
dinosaurios
y al finalizar esta carta había una
frase que decía lucas te acordarás de mí
cuando se hace un famoso paleontólogo en
su momento esa frase no la pude leer por
mi propia cuenta porque como les dije no
sabía leer pero con el tiempo cuando
empecé a aprender a leer y re encontré
este cuadernito de dinosaurios
y lo leí con mis propias por mi propia
cuenta me di cuenta
y tenía una sensación y un sentimiento
que era muy difícil de expresar en
palabras fue como esta sensación que uno
tiene cuando termina de leer un cuento
una historia y se topa con la frase
colorín colorado este cuento se acaba
en ese momento yo me dije a mí mismo yo
quiero seguir aprendiendo quiero seguir
siendo un arte quiero seguir teniendo
esa mismos' ese mismo sentimiento que
tuve cuando leí esa frase de una profe
que ya tenía un trayecto de vida hecho
ha sido un estudiante un nene de tan
solo 5 años
ay me di cuenta que la vida
uno la puede transitar de la mano de la
ciencia y que en sí la ciencia es un
modo de vida este camino que empecé a
recorrer me hizo conocer a gente
increíble y a proyectos hermosos pero
más que nada amplió mis horizontes me di
cuenta que a mi alrededor en mi barrio
en la escuela y hasta en mi grupo amigos
había un montón de personas hombres
mujeres niños y niñas que seguían
compartiendo esta pasión por la ciencia
me di cuenta que no estaba solo me di
cuenta que no era el único raro
dando la vuelta al mundo sino que a mi
alrededor había muchos bichos raros y
eso fue hermoso porque no estaba solo
este camino de hecho recorrer diferentes
espacios en 2018 esta curiosidad que
tengo me subí a un avión con rumbo a
loja ecuador
allí participé de una olimpiada
iberoamericana de biología una
experiencia increíble donde tuve la
posibilidad de conocer
estudiantes de secundaria de todas
partes de latinoamérica y del mundo
si bien muchas veces no nos poníamos de
acuerdo porque teníamos palabras y hasta
conceptos e idiomas diferentes
cuando hablamos de algún término más
bien nardo o alguna curiosidad
todos nos entendíamos en ese momento
todos estábamos hablando un lenguaje
universal el de la ciencia
ahí entendí que la ciencia además de ser
entendida como un modo de vida la
podríamos entender como un hermoso
lenguaje que nos hermane porque al
hablar el lenguaje de la ciencia no hay
fronteras no hay diferencias culturales
sino que somos todos una hermosa
población de niños que nos entendemos
pasaron los años
y como yo les digo fui entendiendo que
la ciencia es un lenguaje
como en todo el lenguaje hay personas
que tienen más y menos afinidad por
hablar pero todos
internamente tenemos esa capacidad
innata de hablar el lenguaje científico
lo único que necesitamos es empezar a
ver al mundo con otros ojos darnos
cuenta que el mundo en sí mismo es un
océano gigantesco de cosas por descubrir
y un universo en hermoso que no está
esperando para explorarlo
eso fue lo más lindo que me enseñó a
este camino que soy transita ahora bien
no todo es color de rosas en la ciencia
eso no se los voy a discutir la ciencia
tiene sus defectos y uno como estudiante
se da cuenta de eso personalmente creo
que uno de los defectos más importantes
que puede tener la ciencia reside en la
divulgación científica esta tarea de
transmitir el mensaje de la ciencia a
toda la sociedad
el verdadero talón de aquiles reside ahí
la ciencia tiene que formar a buenos
divulgadores científicos
porque todo el lenguaje necesita buenos
intérpretes que logren transmitir este
mensaje y que ese mensaje sea llano y
que alcance a toda la sociedad porque si
nosotros sembramos una ciencia que esté
desvinculada de la sociedad y también de
la naturaleza el día de mañana
tendremos una ciencia que no dará frutos
y eso es muy triste
ahora bien ustedes se podrán preguntar
qué rol podemos tener nosotros los
estudiantes la nueva generación en
empezar a difundir este mensaje de la
ciencia yo creo que podemos tener un rol
más que importante podemos ser la
generación que guíe y que ilumine a los
niños y especialmente las niñas podemos
mostrarles que está bueno ser nerd que
está bueno seguir formándose que está
bueno seguir aprendiendo empezar a
transitar este camino de la ciencia y a
su vez podemos mostrarles que uno puede
estudiar una carrera científica y
disfrutar todos y cada uno de los
momentos que uno va experimentando
con este mensaje yo quiero llegar esos
lucas toxo lino de tan solo cinco años
que querían hacer un curso que querían
tragarse el mundo aprender todo lo que
estuviera a su alcance quiero mostrarles
que este camino de la ciencia es posible
que uno puede vivir su vida de una forma
mágica
bien
como le digo la ciencia y la naturaleza
son cosas que a veces uno las toma como
diferentes pero la naturaleza y la
ciencia
tienen lenguajes que pueden ir a la
sintonía
un poeta chileno una persona bohemia que
no estaba vinculada con la ciencia tenía
una idea parecida en los dijo sabiamente
una vez una frase que decía el día en el
que mi voz deje de escucharse el bosque
hablara por mí en su lenguaje de raíces
y yo agrego el bien que nosotros
empecemos a enraizar nos empecemos a
comprometernos con la sociedad con la
naturaleza y con la ciencia cualquier
persona cualquier niño cualquier niña
desde los diferentes lugares que ocupe
podrá hablar hacer y comprometerse con
la ciencia hablemos de ciencia en
nuestro grupo de amigos en nuestra
escuela en la universidad en todos lados
seamos verdaderos actores sociales
seamos actores
científicos muchas gracias